In this part of our tutorial we're going to be taking a look at ways we can optimize our static
and skeletal meshes so that they perform across multiple platforms in a way that is predictable
and how we expect. The first thing that we're going to be talking about is system units.
Now before you can start creating anything in your project it's really important to set your
system units correctly and this doesn't matter which digital content creation program you are
using. In this demo we'll be using 3ds max but the same principle applies to any digital content
creation program or DCC. Unreal Engine 5 uses centimeters as its default unit of measurement
so your DCC should match that to ensure everything imports the correct scale.
Getting the scale right is critical for a good user experience. If your assets are too large or
too small or inconsistent in size it can completely break the immersion which is especially
important in things like VR experiences. Proper scale is also critical for Nanite fallback meshes
which rely on accurate proportions for performance and visual fidelity.
So again remember that Unreal 5 uses centimeters. One unreal unit equals one centimeter and the
easiest way to make sure that you adhere to this is to set the system units of your digital
content creation program to use centimeters. The next thing we're going to talk about in
mesh optimizations is Nanite and when to use it. The short answer is use it anywhere and everywhere
you can. There's a small fixed overhead for having Nanite enabled so in most cases it
actually makes sense to take advantage of it rather than turn it off. Nanite typically uses
less memory and fewer resources than traditional static meshes while maintaining the same visual
qualities your high resolution source assets and it also helps reduce draw calls meaning you can
combine multiple materials on a single mesh without performance loss which simplifies your
scene setup. The only reason to really not use Nanite is if your target platform doesn't support
it and right here we can see two similar static meshes one with Nanite enabled and one
with Nanite disabled. So we have our static mesh up here and our Nanite mesh and at first glance
they look relatively the same but if we look at them in a little more detail we're going to
start to see some really significant differences. For example the area that we have highlighted here
on the static mesh we can definitely see the polygonal lines like this is definitely
a 3D mesh but if we look at the Nanite mesh notice that this is no longer a polygonal line
in fact the line actually goes up and down it has highs and lows or much like we would expect
if we were looking at the side of an object in the real world so we can see just from this
example the type of fidelity and resolution that we are getting with Nanite. Now one of the other
things that we need to know about Nanite is how it generates a fallback mesh so right here in this
example we have this a robot which we'll take a look at in the editor in a second this is the
Nanite mesh and this is the static mesh fallback. The fallback mesh is what gets used for things
like ray tracing, collision, other non-nanite systems, and platforms that don't necessarily
support Nanite. So inside the static mesh editor there are a few settings that you can use to
adjust the geometry or reduce the geometry of both the Nanite mesh and the static mesh
fallback. These settings are called keep triangle percentage this lets you reduce the triangle
count to optimize performance and then trim relative error this increases how aggressively
Nanite trims geometry which can significantly reduce disk space usage. Now you can quickly
go between the Nanite mesh and the static mesh fallback in the static mesh editor by
hitting ctrl n and we will take a look at that right now so inside of unreal I'm gonna just
close this window real quick we're gonna hit ctrl space we're gonna open up our smbot there we go
and we do have Nanite for this so if I hit ctrl n you can see here as soon as I do that
it says showing fallback and then we see the values right here and then if I want to do
anything over here under the details panel in the Nanite settings we have our keep triangle
percentage just put this down to 50 and hit apply we're going to see what this is going to
do is it's going to take our fallback triangles to write about half of the number that they
were before and I do believe that I need to do this to the percent triangles here there we go
wrong one that was the keep that's for disk size I wanted the fallback size right there so
right there about 40 we'll hit apply changes and there we go that's what we're looking for
is the fallback triangles right there so again it hit about half that size
for platforms that don't support Nanite there is the built-in level of detail tool that can be
found inside of the static mesh and the skeletal mesh editor with this tool you can have unreal
programmatically generate different versions of your static mesh that are reduced in triangle
count we can see an example of that here this little cow taken from the starter content
starts at 2500 triangles and using the tool we can actually reduce this down to 1200
600 and 300 triangles respectively now these numbers are not set in stone it's a good to start
reducing at around 75 percent for LOD 1, 25 percent for LOD 2, and then 12 percent for LOD 3
but these are just suggestions you should test and use numbers that work best for the project
that you happen to be working on now keep in mind that you can apply level of detail
adjustments to both your static and your skeletal meshes static meshes have a slightly simpler
interface with static meshes you have the ability to select their termination based off
of the triangle count the vertice count or a combination of both making options very very
simple for static mesh LOD creation skeletal meshes on the other hand have a slightly more
robust reduction tool and that's because skeletal meshes have to be reduced but also have that
reduction work with things like morph targets and animations let's just take a quick look at
the editor really quick and inside of our smbot here or inside of a static mesh we're going to
look at setting this up to have some level of detail so first we come down to our LOD settings
number of LODs we're going to set this to three and hit apply changes and this is actually
how simple it is to do this now that it has finished processing if we come over here to our
LODs we can go LOD0, LOD1, and LOD2 if we click on LOD auto the LODs will automatically change
as I move further and closer away to this object we can then come here I'm going to go to LOD0
we can come down to the LOD0 settings under its reduction and we can see here the percent
of triangles to keep if we come here to LOD1 you can see here if we come down to our reduction
settings we're at 50 and then we go to LOD2 and again we come down not our sections sorry
reduction and we're at 25 so we can simply just do something like this and hit apply changes
the other great thing about this tool is that it's non-destructive if we need to increase or
further decrease any of the settings in the generated level of details we simply come into
the tool make the reductions press the build button and that is all that we have to do
now as I mentioned before the skeletal mesh tool has a slightly few more options and
one of those options that I want to talk about is the bone priority reduction now what this does
is this will weight any geometry that are skinned to any bones very high so that when the
reduction logarithm is applied to them that geometry will be the last thing to be reduced
and we can actually see a really great example here on the left we have the default reduction
and while this does look like a hand it's actually missing a lot of geometry or it has
a lot of geometry that's been collapsed down to either a single triangle resulting in just
something again that looks kind of like a hand at first glance but it's actually got a lot of
issues by taking all of the bones that are inside of the hand and making sure that their bone
priority reduction was set to a very very high value we can still use that great reduction tool
but now the hand itself still looks like a hand the fingers still look like fingers we don't have
any weird looking geometry or anything like that the next thing I'd like to call out is the
lock open edges this ensures that important vertices are not removed during the reduction
process this feature is especially useful when working with separate body parts in fact we use
this inside of fortnite this is a head you might see this head inside of fortnite and
what I want to call out here is that there is this little triangle right here that's got a
vertice right there that sticks out that needs to be there in order for the head and the neck
to properly align now if we run the the skeletal mesh reduction tools by default that little bit
of geometry will actually get removed and that's going to result in a gap so the uh lock open
edges again allows us to have that correct reduction without removing areas that actually
need to be there so that we don't have any gaps inside of our geometry